all right Ted thank you for that well as
the New Year draws near a series of new
laws will go into effect so we want to
break it all down here for you which
includes benefits for electric car
drivers now the first law will give a
boost in charging stations that is SB 44
which allows more charging stations in
uh areas for the electric cars and
specifically in low-income homes and
neighborhoods now the goal is to help
keep us all on track for that 50 clean
energy by 2030 law also
ab116t now this one here is a law that
switches minor traffic tickets from
Criminal to civil for example you won't
get a bench warrant for not paying a
basic ticket you will get a bill
collector so also moving on AB 349 now
this law here aims to close the classic
car license plate loophole chances are
you've probably seen those so-called
Clunkers with classic plates which
allows them to bypass a smog check well
there's about 30 000 of them after the
new year they will be required to have
the class classic car insurance also we
want to tell you about AB 30 360. that
one goes into effect which involves
tobacco purchases now if a clerk doesn't
ask for someone's ID under the age of 40
they can get a 100 civil fine and
finally SB 186 this one introduces a
thing called common interest communities
this is a protection for owners as well
as renters stating that they can't buy a
unit after an HOA foreclosed on someone
or anyone involved in the Foreclosure
can't buy them and of course they must
maintain a website and make any
documents available online so